six days after haiti's devastating
earthquake life-saving and has and has
not reached some of the hardest hit
parts of the country a release shipment
did reach this rural town yesterday and
hundreds of people lined up for food a
mudslide earlier this week had blocked
the main road into the area vladimir
duty is in port-au-prince and has
visited several of those towns where
people need help vlad good morning
good morning anthony each day that
passes the mood here gets more tense as
people wait for relief and word on
whether missing loved ones are dead or
alive one thing really slowing it down
is the infrastructure poorly constructed
roads many of which are patrolled by
gangs are making it harder to get food
and water and medical supplies to those
who desperately
and her sister were buried under a
mountain of rubble when their four-story
apartment building collapsed during
saturday's earthquake she says that her
sister was at her side and she could
hear her sister screaming but she
couldn't do anything because she herself
was trapped
more than 12 000 people were injured
across haiti
it took six hours for a rescue team to
dig olly and out her aunt tells us
olean's sister was killed along with
many of their neighbors including young
children
she says that three children were pulled
from the rubble yesterday
and they died
in the ambulance on the way to the
hospital
many survivors are being treated at
hospitals operated or supported by
independent disaster relief groups
we saw their efforts firsthand here at
this hospital run by doctors without
borders victims of the earthquake are
brought here transported by aircraft
where they're stabilized once they're
stabilized they're taken to local area
hospitals where they undergo major
surgery
this is the second major earthquake a
generation of patients have survived if
we kill each other
they mean this already
thirty-year-old reginald
told us he lived through the country's
2010 earthquake and says when he felt
the building shake this time he knew he
only had two choices either i'm going to
die here because the building is going
to pancake on me or i'm going to jump
off this balcony and i may be hurt but
at least i'll be alive
reginald jumped from that second floor
balcony he fractured his vertebrae and
injured his arm in the process there is
some good news gail usaid partners have
handed out thousands of hygiene kits to
those in need and a surgical team from
the u.s navy is set to arrive this
weekend we certainly crave good news and
feeling for reginald most people go
through their lives never go through one
earthquake he's been through too thank
you vladimir duter reporting from haiti